a heart surgeon took his car to his
local garage for a regular service where
he usually exchanged the friendly banter
with the owner a skilled mechanic so
tell me says the mechanic i've been
wondering about what we both do for a
living and how much more you get paid
than me yes as the surgeon well look at
this says the mechanic as he worked on a
big complicated engine i check how it's
running open it up fix the valves put it
all back together so it works good as
new we basically do the same job but
don't we and yet you get paid way more
than me how do you explain that the
surgeon thought for a moment smiled and
replied
try it with the engine running
differences in perception are present
throughout our everyday interactions the
instance with the doctor and the
mechanic was picked just to illustrate
how people can interpret different life
experiences based on their own
perception and understanding of the
world most of our problems in our
everyday endeavors stem from our
inability to understand the power of
perception and how this can affect one's
life and experiences i like to call
those problems problems of perception
and their typical consequences include
the feeling of disappointment and being
let down by others
getting into disagreements and verbal
fights
experiencing disconnection and isolation
accusing others of being responsible for
your own problems such issues can have a
detrimental effect on our psychology
it's not a small thing to have to deal
with a lack of sync in the majority of
human interactions you encounter it can
lead to frustration anxiety anger lack
of motivation and depression and that's
the reason i decided to cover the
concept of perception in this video in
our attempts to pursue a lasting effect
of abundance in our lives understanding
perception can become an invaluable tool
in our mental toolbox
remember the infamous blue and black
dress that tore the internet apart some
years ago although it was confirmed that
the color of the dress was blue and
black a lot of people saw the dress as
white and gold this was quite an
interesting visual phenomenon that
signifies to a huge extent the power of
perception in our everyday lives because
of different processes that take place
in the brain of each individual the way
we perceive things compared to others
may vary significantly even the
slightest difference in perception that
is caused by let's say an insignificant
dress can cause debate and in some cases
even arguments between individuals who
just want to prove themselves right the
way that things look feel smell taste
and sound is not necessarily the way
they really are though things may appear
to be color to us our experiences of
color are merely representative of the
surface properties of objects the
physical property of reflecting certain
wavelengths of light and the color red
as we experience it are two quite
different things in our attempt however
to justify our perceptual thinking what
we fail to recognize is that perception
is molding our reality and especially
the quality of our relationships through
problems of perception we fail to grasp
the essence of the world around us we
constantly communicate with other people
but we rarely understand them but how
can you really try and understand
another person if you are constantly
limited by the narrow boundaries that
your own perception dictates this
process can only be achieved by
initiating a perceptual shift a shift
that will gradually disengage you from
your own perception and give you the
incredibly powerful ability to see the
world through the eyes of others while
doing some research on the topic of
perception i stumbled upon a mindfulness
coach named shelly tigielski her views
on the topic are quite enlightening
the world is an idea more specifically
the world is your idea this sentence
didn't come to me organically it was
first expressed by the great 19th
century philosopher arthur soppenhauer
in his seminal work the world as will
and representation
no truth is more absolutely certain than
that all that exists for knowledge and
therefore this whole world is only
objects in relation to subject
perception of a perceiver in a word idea
the world his idea if only he knew that
after almost two centuries his writings
would have such a huge impact on the way
that we communicate and shape our
relationships whenever people have
arguments they usually lose touch with
reality because they get caught up in
their idea of the world when we fight
with others we hear our perception of
others words gestures and so forth we
make meaning out of what others
communicate based on that this may or
may not match the meaning they tend to
convey if i am offended by others it is
important to understand that i am
actually offended by what i do with
their words based on how i made meaning
out of them in essence i am offended by
them in me not by them the real person i
can never experience them the real
person directly in the end i'm offended
by none other than myself in short it is
not what people do to me that causes
problems for me but what i do with
people to cause myself problems the
power of reframing is unquestionable for
instance when somebody insults me
instead of thinking
x told me i'm bad at y
i can reframe this into i had x in me
telling me that i'm bad at why this
change in perception of how you
experience other opinions instantly
helps you release tension with reframing
when you respond to the person you are
responding to your perception you are
responding to you there are huge
benefits to understanding and
communicating with this in mind when i
really get this principle a whole new
world in me opens up
suddenly i don't take things personally
i do not get offended very easily i can
listen to criticism with an open mind i
don't take myself so seriously or
believe that others have power over me
a common issue when it comes to
perception is that we usually act
passively and not actively to the
processes we experience we tend to
victimize ourselves when people interact
with us in a negative way she made me
feel so angry my father makes me feel
helpless i'm troubled by my past in
reality i am the one doing the acting
i actively create my own experience with
perceptual change i express myself
differently i anger myself with hair i
make myself feel helpless when i am with
my father i travel myself with my past
this way of putting words together
suggests that i'm an active participant
in my own experience
i'm doing things to myself as opposed to
having things done to me the difference
between i am troubled by my past and i
travel myself with my past is huge there
is a clear lack of responsibility in the
first sentence whereas the second
communicates a person that is
characterized by self-reliance
self-reliance allows you to act upon
your problem
you change from the victim to the person
in control
and control is the bedrock of
self-ownership
when we work with our perception and the
things we experience we think that we
are experiencing a combination of past
present and future acts that's not true
now is all we have you are experiencing
yourself in the now and past and future
are just parameters that distort the
idea of now especially when we speak
about the past and the future we fail to
recognize that we do it within the
premise of now when you say for instance
tomorrow is going to be a scary day this
becomes i scare myself with my thoughts
about tomorrow or my parents mistreated
me when i was a child this becomes i
trouble myself now with thoughts of
being mistreated when i was a child
so the world i interact with is within
me i actively create it right now
perceptual change makes this healing
concepts a reality after experimenting
with it for quite some time i came to
understand that when others judge me i
am actually using my perception of them
to judge myself i also realized that
what others refer to is just their
perception of me not me perception forms
the foundation of our world when we
change the structure of our perception
we change the structure of our
world hey guys hope you enjoyed today's
video if you did make sure to like
subscribe turn on notifications and
comment below something cool please so
that more people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon adrian out